david bonjour alors après les
interventions chinoises françaises et
allemandes c'est la lumière poutine qui
doit prendre la parole aujourd'hui
effectivement c'est ce qu'a confirmé à
dmitri peskov une première depuis à 2009
pour le chef d'état russe et qui s
exprimera à midi heure française
elle porte parole de du kremlin n'a pas
voulu donner de détails sur
l'intervention de vladimir poutine mais
a priori son discours devrait porter sur
la manière dont le monde change
elle suit à la pandémie a dû couronna
virus exposé en outre les nouveaux défis
auxquels vont être confrontés est les
puissances mondiales
à noter également les interventions du
premier ministre israélien benyamin
netanyahu et du président un sud-coréen
moudjahidine
l'impact économique du coc u19 sujets
essentiels de ce forum conventionnelle
est un peu particulier cette année
puisque la distance yale mais les enjeux
sont tout aussi importants à savoir à
lutter contre les résines égalité creusé
par cette épidémie a rappelé également
que cette pandémie a fait perdre 2 125
millions d'emplois selon l'organisation
internationale du travail alors qu'en
parallèle les grandes fortunes n'ont
pratiquement rien a perdu mais ce n'est
pas tout c'est aussi l'occasion de
mettre les puissances économiques du
monde de ce monde devant leurs
responsabilités
c'est le cas notamment des états unis en
particulier sur la valeur la hyène la
commissaire européen européenne a
notamment pas hésité hier à les
interpeller sur la régulation des géants
du numérique notamment
c est un projet qui lui tient
particulièrement à coeur la présidente
de la commission européenne souhaite que
les etats-unis rejoignent les
initiatives européennes en référence
notamment au dernier événement du à
capitol ursula von der leyen s'est dit
choqué par tant de violence et
ambitionne un changement radical
concernant les dangers d'internet
l'yonne qui n'est pas la seule à avoir
incriminé les états unis a en tout cas
cette fois ça s'est fait de manière plus
discrète
alors oui il y avait un petit sonore un
tiers seulement des ryan qu'on pourra
écouter années plus tard
pardon d'accord mais showmatch des
tuteurs sur un vaisseau ses actes la
commission a lancé la loi sur les
services numériques et la loi sur le
marché numérique en décembre il s'agit
de notre nouveau règlement pour le
marché numérique et je souhaite inviter
les amis américains à se joindre à nos
initiatives jean et ensemble nous
pourrions créer un règlement sur
l'économie numérique qui soit valable
dans le monde entier
qu'irait de la protection des données et
de la vie privée à la sécurité des
infrastructures critiques tout security
of quick est comme une fois je pense que
je alors voilà cette nouvelle
législation dont elle parle elle était
votée le 15 décembre dernier est à la
fois projet de mettre fin aux dérives de
ces géants du numérique accusée d'abuser
de leur pouvoir et de contribuer à
répondre des discours dangereux le
règlement sur les services numériques
elle doit responsabiliser l'ensemble des
plateformes et particulièrement les plus
grandes qui devront disposer de moyens
pour modérer à les contenus qu'elle
accueille et coopérer avec les autorités
une dizaine d'entreprises sont
concernées et parmi elles les cinq gars
femme à un google apple facebook amazon
et microsoft
alors du coup david on a entendu à
ursula vendre des réveillonnent et ce n
est pas la seule à avoir incriminé les
états unis en tout cas cette fois ça
s'est fait de manière un peu plus
discrète sans jamais les nommer
effectivement un sitting ping s'est posé
en défenseur du multilatéralisme et de
la mondialisation le président chinois
appellent à la solidarité dans ce
contexte particulier et met en garde
implicitement washington - du moins
d'une semaine après l arrivée l de dubaï
donne à la maison blanche
objectif stopper la politique chinoise
de son prédécesseur qui avait fait de la
chine son rival numéro 1 notamment sur
les plans commercial et technologique
bâtir des clans ou déclencher une
nouvelle guerre froide rejeté menacé ou
intimidé les autres imposer le
découplage le bouleversement des chaînes
d'approvisionnement ou des sanctions
afin de provoquer d'isolement ne fera
que pousser le monde
la division et même la confrontation
dans le monde actuel l'approché rhône et
de l'antagonisme de la confrontation que
ce soit sous la forme d'une guerre
froide du lider à chaud d'une guerre
commerciale d'une guerre technologique
finirait par nuire aux intérêts de
chaque nation et par sacrifier le
bien-être des gens autres sous-entendu
éviter que joe biden ressoude elle les
occidentaux face à lui quoi qu'il en
soit ce forum de davos vous l'aurez
compris elle permet de transmettre ce
message au monde et à distance c'est
souvent plus facile à vérifier merci
beaucoup d'avis de qualifiable pour
toutes ces précisions